another week another day in a world
better than our world called The
Apocalypse too much is that too dark
well you clicked on my face this is what
you get thank you for clicking on my
face though do appreciate that there you
go a little bit of optimism the world is
[__] though so these are my thoughts on
episode 8 of The Last of Us as a spoiler
warning going to talk about the goings
on of episode 8 of The Last of Us also
gonna we'll give some thoughts and
comparisons with how the game did it
hopefully it doesn't come across as
[__] it just sounded when I said it
but just rather thoughts that's the
spoiler warning you've been warned
generally speaking of this episode did
do the chapter Justice these are the
episodes the episodes you can't help but
look forward to
like when The Last of Us series was
announced I was like oh great the finale
and cannibals can't wait you know how it
is just can't help but look forward to
these things so yeah in this episode
Joel's still out he's he's down for the
count he has this infection Ellie needs
help she goes out there and she shoots a
deer runs across a couple folks from
this community it's a very nice
Community they eat venison trust me on
that or them trust them on that don't do
that in the apocalypse if people are
eating well and they're eating meat
they're eating folks those are people in
stew pots in this episode it does the
thing that the last of us has largely
been doing which is when you're dealing
with this faction Town Group whatever
they show you a little more with them so
you understand them a little better see
a little bit of the dude the preacher
guy running the show doing what leaders
in the apocalypse do recite lines from
Titanic
twist it wasn't the Bible it's actually
the Titanic script he's written off it's
like I don't know
[__] enthralled everyone in 97 so the
dudes hanging out with Troy Baker
thought that was a great Cameo Troy
Baker gets to play the other dude who
meets up with Ellie and they're pretty
much like um you're not hauling the deer
so all right we'll trade you penicillin
um and we'll just chill and talk for a
bit that's when the dude's like
everything happens for a reason I mean
the dialogue is so close to the game
which is what I love about this it also
shows that the dialogue that's why the
game when it came out was instantly like
people are like this is a [__] movie
so they don't actually have to change
much for the series to work and they
know that and I appreciate that they
know that dude was like I know you're
traveling with a guy who killed some of
my crew some weeks ago that's the show
telling us Joel's been out of commission
for weeks so that's where you get that
but I thought it was a better visual cue
in the game to have hey it's winter
there's snow now when there wasn't snow
before and you're like oh it's been
weeks clearly then Ellie with penicillin
shot in hand gives Joel a shot right in
the wound on the stomach does that work
I'm legitimately asking I've never heard
of it I've never heard of a penicillin
shot going directly into the wound let
alone the ab muscle it's always like ass
cheek right there that that's where it
goes this is a real question so I don't
want to inadvertently kill somebody in
the apocalypse all right well that's how
well he did it oh well you died because
I took my medical advice from a 14 year
old character in a fictional show let's
not have that happen point is they take
Ellie back to the town she's behind bars
I'm gonna do talking with her having
that heart to heart like look you should
hang out here we could do great things
together you and me I see it you look
like the Target demographic for Titanic
have you seen Titanic it's like all my
sermons and I thought they did the whole
they have the audience spend a little
bit of time with these folks who are
clearly eating people but don't really
know it like I thought they did that
really well I was kind of afraid that
okay this is the first time they've
eaten people and this is just Ellie
might be the second person they eat
where in the game I was like you've
eaten folks for a while and it looks
that way until you see more bot is
hanging up and it's like okay so they're
a little bit of people who know about it
and the rest of people are just like
venison yeah sounds good really [__]
up but in the apocalypse you join a
community these are the gambles and this
being the Ellie Coming of Age Arc the
entire time I was afraid they were going
to have Joel kick the door in and
actually take the dude out and it
doesn't go down that way Ellie is Ellie
kills this guy with a Vengeance just
bludgeons living [__] [__] out of him
it was a blade but still felt like
bludgeons what can I say again very
accurate to the game and in a world
where this show actually The Last of Us
I constantly am met with this feeling of
I wish they balanced more action or
sprinkled more action in with the drama
granted gun to my head I have to choose
one I would rather them show drama wins
absolutely we have action with no real
character development or drama you just
have things happening you have drama
with less action you still have a human
experience you can sink your teeth into
so they chose well absolutely but there
are moments I wish there was more action
sprinkled in not with Ellie in this
situation I do think her one kill in the
episode and in this chapter being the
guy like the main guy I felt that was
actually done really well and very
important having Ellie go around stealth
killing folk how I like to do it it
would have compromised that but on the
other hand the previous episode I knew
this from the comment section anyway you
know it's like oh one clicker comes in
and bites them both but I guess it was a
horde of them in the DLC that's a
constant in the show I met with that
feeling of I wish there was a bigger
group of people that had to take on I
wish there were more clickers they had
to take on example when she's having her
heart to heart with the dude his name
David I think it's David the guy who
recites Titanic lines they hear clickers
they're like all right well we gotta
team up and he was pulled in the pistol
she didn't know about it so they team up
and they have to take out these clickers
that's an action sequence I actually
felt played into the character Dynamic
there because when the guy's like a by
the way ever gonna boil you into stew I
was like dude we killed clickers
together you Hannibal elector minus the
PHD dick like come on I felt like a big
betrayal but this series thus far has
had the drama of the characters front
and center and I appreciate that you
know what I like about this and the fact
that I almost called this a revisit but
this is actually a first visit of the
last of a show but it feels like a
revisit to The Last of Us world which is
a good thing Joel straight up kneecap
stabbing that dude and bludgeoning the
other guy with the pipe after he gets
the answer Joel is willing to do a lot
of [__] some dark [__] to keep Ellie
safe like Joel hugging Ellie saying I
got you baby girl you know like he's
accepted her as that daughter figure as
she's accepted him as a father figure
I'm looking forward to next week I feel
bad for all the people out there who've
been so hyped about The Last of Us
finale they're gonna watch it I feel
like I can't help I feel like they're
gonna be like that's it all in all yeah
solid cannibal episode all right so the
Last of Us episode eight only one
episode left to go have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you see here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]